there are things in OVA that are rarely
discussed acts of violence kept strictly
within the family although there are a
few people willing to help
Jenya Zeca has opened her door to
battered wives and girlfriends she draws
tattoos to help them bury the past which
isn't easy in Russia where the problem
is widely ignored in fact the government
has just decriminalized some acts of
domestic violence muzaka has met
hundreds of victims and she can't forget
what she's seen
but worst of all the gifts not off
beside Sochi Russia yet the more
Caucasian announced welcoming as Apple
would with the oldest shake it started
as a project that's turned into an
essential service an unorthodox way for
women like 28 year-old Vika to deal with
abuse the pair decide on a wolf design
to cover-up marks on because forearm
jenia has already wrapped a butterfly
around a stab wound
the outline was traced the needle dipped
in ink when Vika told us what her
husband and his friend did when she got
pregnant yet she was neither nominee of
macho I mean victim weakest arrived but
many do not government figures show
14,000 Russian women are killed every
year and a new law reducing the penalty
from any acts of domestic violence to a
modest fine could make it worse super
negative cost on the launcher and dummy
and irritation it took several hours to
complete a multicolored artwork that
helps to soothe the pain
we asked Vika about the future Vimala
da-da-da-da-da-da immunity as machinery
coming up the mostest rakia is Boyan is
Diana to talk over to Erica Linea
couture maneuver it's Mario combinations
elastic means no estimate
Russia's new law on domestic violence
sailed through the Russian parliament in
under two weeks but we had trouble
getting the bills backers to speak to us
so we went to the Duma to find them I am
struggling to understand why anybody
would vote for a bill that
decriminalizes violence against women
Elvis Costello solution issued near
decriminalize that same a silly approach
objection i decree me the deserts a yogi
appreciation freedoms that all view but
we've seen here it's all about building
stronger families say the politicians
but in oofah there are some who take
issue with that we made contact with
staff at a shelter for battered women we
don't know where we're going
we're following a shelter employee
taking us there now it's tiny there's
only room for five or six women and
their children
and it's location is a closely kept
secret a thick steel door offers some
protection and an NGO offers support
this one of two small sanctuaries in a
city of 1.2 million the hostel manager
who doesn't get a penny from the
government asked to remain anonymous in
McDonough's polish to some crews nice to
me emotional connection with them I took
oh my god she's insane cutter boomer a
short critic of riemann others machinery
shows it for the most part battered
women and children are on their own the
authorities rarely get involved
we spoke to Olga a mother of two
it was repeatedly beaten by her
boyfriend but sheet recording every
employee Jerusalem Ocho circular motion
Naruto stop not stupid universe model
super apples
[Music]
as for Jennea well she used to lock the
door and weak she tried to cope with
what she'd heard she's found solace in
art pastels on paper as she readies for
another day John sparks Sky News